The Joe Rogan experience,
there's a blog I read about Finn privilege just to sit there.
That's another thing.
That's another way of saying fat shaming.
The other side of saying fat shaming is that being thin you were enjoying thin
privilege and that by creating success and all that,
not just dating success but the way people dress you in,
the way you move around in society that you enjoy thin privilege and what
they're trying to do is compare being in shape with being a white male like
white male privilege is white.
Male privilege is almost shameful.
You know,
it's almost shameful to have this white male privilege while people are stuck.
It's,
it makes you feel,
uh,
like the,
the,
like if someone talks about white male privilege,
what do you think of,
you think of someone being aloof to the concerns of,
of Brown people and poor people and racism and also allude to the fact that they
got super lucky.
They got this lucky roll the dice and were born in this way that allows them to
be.
I mean,
if you think about white males thinking about white males and you think about
wealth,
majority of the like super wealthy people are white males.
The majority of the people that are in positions of power,
whether it's presidents,
mayor,
white males,
so that white male being a white male and have that privilege is almost like
being in a pig.
It's like being the man so thin privilege.
They've figured out a way to make being fin being a pig.
You've got to knock willpower of that list.
There is no lack of willpower and fat people willpower's a finite resource.
You have so much against.
We prove this beyond a doubt.
What do you mean willpower?
There's a whole book about this now,
and I'm forgetting the name of the author,
but they actually show that there's so many decisions you can make.
I wrote about this a while back.
There's decision making fatigue and there's x amount of willpower and you can
apply that will power to change the world.
Or you can apply that willpower to say no to the bowl of chips in front of you.
Right?
And if you're a fat person and your energy reserves are low,
and I say this from personal experience,
the amount of willpower it takes to get up off the couch and walk across the
street and do whatever you're going to do,
it requires a hell of a lot more weird,
more willpower than you would think it would as a healthy person because your
cells aren't working,
you don't have the energy,
and yet you get up and you do it in every step you take is sapping your
willpower in a way a healthy person doesn't have.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
Saying that even though willpower is sort of an individual characteristic and
some people have it,
some people don't.
With fat people,
it's almost like a catch 22 because although they need it to drop away,
they're not gonna have it because they needed to just move around.
Their energy levels are lower so they have less willpower and they're using the
willpower to do simple things that are effortless for you and it's not
effortless for a fat person.
That is such an interesting point and one that I really didn't consider.
That's a very unique point because I,
I never really considered that fat people like,
it's almost like they can't help themselves.
It's almost like they're,
we'll or it's so much more difficult for them to pass on shitty food than it is
a regular person.
Well,
think of it like this.
If you're a regular person that's been privileged.
What branch of the military army?
How long were you in for?
Three.
Three years?
Well,
six years total.
What year was this?
80 two to 85 and then reserves from 85 to eight years.
Let's you BA boom.
You out a wig.
That's just real.
Yo.
Did you get anything out of being in the military?
Yeah,
discipline.
Yeah.
Just,
you know,
just again,
just being,
being responsible response ability,
the ability to respond.
Yeah.
People that have gone through that,
it's very interesting to see.
I had a friend who was a real lazy and Kinda shiftless and never got anything
done and then went away,
went to bootcamp,
came back and this motherfucker always folded his napkin after that.
Sat Up Straight and got shit done and I was like,
wow.
They turned this dude around like they're really did.
I wouldn't recommend it today because joining today have a high likelihood of
either being forced to assassinate someone for the government or finding
yourself in a position where you really wouldn't want to be and people are
shooting out you that don't like Americans and unless it's your calling,
I wouldn't really recommend it.
But goddamn,
for some people it really is a game changer.
I agree.
Yeah.
And not all.
Not everyone can make it through it.
It's.
But the,
a lot of guys that kind of washed out during that whole basic training.
What made you join College Fund for Art School?
Really?
Will you pretty convinced that we weren't going to go to war during those times
completely.
I was like,
war,
you know,
I didn't,
I just didn't believe it.
And then uh,
I got,
I got appointed to go,
I got a long process,
but basically it got handed a,
an opportunity to go to west point by going to the preparatory school for a year
and uh,
got to the end when I finally got my appointment to go to west point,
they said basically you have to forfeit your army college fund to go to art
school.
And I didn't really go into be a career military person.
I kind of went into get college fund so I can go pursue the arts,
but,
you know,
but you're being,
again,
I was being my behavior as being ready to forest as far as my,
the way I was excelling as an in the military.
Um,
so it was very tempting to go,
I can be an officer,
let's do that.
And then you get,
you know,
it got to that moment where I had to,
like,
I had to make that decision in that moment.
You have basically I had like three hours to check the yes box that accept my
appointment or check the no box and you know,
go back into the regular army.
And they go back to them,
go to art school and I chose,
I chose art school.
Alright.
And I,
if I had not done that,
I would have provided I made it through west point,
which is not a guarantee.
If I'd have made it through west point,
I would have been in the first Gulf war as a lieutenant.
Wow.
That's fucking crazy.
Well,
it also begs the question,
all of this stuff begs the question like,
first of all,
everyone's favorite argument is if you have nothing to hide then what are you
worried about?
And it's not that.
What it is is first of all,
why do you need so much information and what?
What have you done that have made so many people so angry?
They have to check everyone's email.
Like what is the actual cause of all this that never gets addressed.
Like whenever we're talking about how this group hates us of that group hates us
and this group is playing.
Why?
What did we do?
I want to go with what you said that the if you have nothing to hide,
because I was just.
I was trying to get a show up before I came here and I failed miserably,
but one of the things I was going to talk about,
did you see that story?
The lawsuit filed from that incident in New Mexico with the driver who didn't do
the full stop leaving Walmart.
You saw it,
right?
Right.
So.
So the police pulled them over for,
for California,
stopping the stop sign.
Decide that he looks like he's clenching his buttocks in a weird way,
and this is the part I love most to a judge and says to the judge while this guy
is sitting on the side of the road,
he's clenching his buttocks.
In a weird way.
I think we have somebody trying to hide drugs in there and the judge goes,
I guess judging from the story,
yeah,
that would be probable cause.
So they take this guy to a doctor who refuses to do with the police officers
asked.
So they've got to go to another doctor.
Fourteen hours of anal cavity searches,
enemas.
They sedated him and did a colonoscopy.
They examined his stuff right in front of him.
Fourteen hours,
found nothing.
X rayed him multiple times,
found nothing,
and then apparently send them a $6,000 bill for the procedure.
So when you say,
what have you got to hide if any,
you.
Unless you're Heidi,
that's what can happen to you if.
And not just that.
What I love is the police department spokesman said,
we didn't do anything wrong.
This is policy,
and we had a judge sign off on it.
So when you say,
if you have nothing to hide,
what do you care?
This guy had nothing to hide and that happened to him.
Clearly did because he was away.
I know,
but now now that story's true and the lawsuit,
claims witnesses and all this kind of stuff and the police officers think
nothing was wrong there.
That's what happens to you when you get rid of these protections that keep you
from being searched willy nilly or anything like that.
But after a story like that,
everyone in the ward was going to be stopped by the police.
Who's going to clean this bathroom a weird way.
It's just the theater of the stories,
like
people that are bought freaks and that's what they're into.
They're into cops checking them out and treasures up there,
put secrets up there too.
I didn't mean to take the conversation though.
It's a great direction.
It's hilarious.
It's.
Well,
it's fucked up that if you search,
someone's asked for 14 hours and there's nothing up there.
That guy should be able to search your house for 28.
That should be the rule.
You should be able to throw firecrackers in there.
And come on,
man.
He checked his ass for no reason.
Like you owe him something.
What bothers me about that is that there's no penalty that actually affects the
people who did this.
In other words,
if this guy wins is big lawsuit against them,
that's the taxpayers who are going to pay that.
The people who did it don't suffer at all.